THE SENATE WILL COME TO ORDER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DARLEY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND GUESTS. BE
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE RISE. WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SISTER GORMAN, THANK YOU. AND
LET US BRING OURSELVES INTO THE
PRESENCE OF OUR GOD. GOD OF THE
SMALL, THE SUBTLE, THE
UNIMPORTANT. GOD OF THE VAGUE.
THE CLOUDY. THE AMBIGUOUS. OPEN
OUR HEARTS TO YOUR PRESENCE.
OPEN OUR EYES TO THE LITTLE
SIGNS. OUR EARS TO THE SOFT
MURMURS. SLOW US DOWN TO LISTEN.
AND HEAR. THE CRIES OF THE
UNSPOKEN. AWAKEN US TO THE
LOSSES THAT ARE BLESSINGS.
AWAKEN US TO THE WOUNDS THAT ARE
OPENINGS. AWAKEN US TO THE
WEAKNESSES THAT ARE SOURCES OF
YOUR STRENGTH. WAKE US FROM THE
STUPOR OF BUSYNESS. THE DAYS OF
DESIRE NHÀ AND KEEP US WOKE TO
WITNESS YOUR DRAWING NEAR TO
BEHOLD YOUR PRESENCE EVEN IN
THESE ORDINARY MOMENTS, THESE
FEEBLE PRAYERS, THESE BEATING
HEARTS. AMEN. MEMBERS AND
GUESTS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG STATES OF
AMERICA, FOR WHICH STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE,
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
.
MEMBERS MEMBERS, WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WILL TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING RESOLUTION. OUT OF
ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS. THIS IS SR 82.
IT'S FILED ITEM 35. AFTER
ADOPTION OF THE RESOLUTION, WILL
RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR FOR THE AUTHOR TO
INTRODUCE THEIR GUESTS. LET'S
JUST GIVE IT A MOMENT HERE,
MEMBERS, IF YOU COULD RETURN TO
YOUR CHAIRS, PLEASE. MEMBERS, IF
YOU COULD RETURN TO YOUR CHAIRS,
PLEASE.
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS,
PLEASE. MOBILE, PLEASE. IT'S A
RESOLUTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 82 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. RELATIVE TO
WORLD PRESS FREEDOM DAY. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MEMBERS. I AM HAPPY TO
RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE RESOLUTION
82. THIS RESOLUTION COMMEMORATES
WORLD PRESS FREEDOM DAY, WHICH
IS TOMORROW, MAY 3RD. WORLD
PRESS FREEDOM DAY WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE UNITED
NATIONS GENERAL ASSEMBLY IN 1993
TO RAISE AWARENESS WORLDWIDE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS AND TO
REMIND GOVERNMENTS OF THEIR DUTY
TO RESPECT AND UPHOLD THE
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION ON THIS
DAY, WE HONOR AND RECOGNIZE THE
DEDICATION, INTEGRITY AND
BRAVERY OF JOURNALISTS WHO WORK
TIRELESSLY TO UNCOVER THE TRUTH,
KEEP THE PUBLIC INFORMED, AND
SERVE AS A WATCHDOG OVER
GOVERNMENT. WE KNOW THAT FREEDOM
OF THE PRESS IS SO CRITICAL TO
FORMING AND NURTURING A
DEMOCRACY THAT IS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PEOPLE THAT OUR NATION'S
FOUNDERS PROTECTED IT BY PUTTING
IT IN THE VERY FIRST AMENDMENT
TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION. IN MODERN
DEMOCRACIES, JOURNALISTS PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE. THEY INFORM US
ABOUT OUR GOVERNMENT, OUR COURTS
AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY AND WHAT
THEY ARE DOING. JOURNALISTS JOB
IS TO REPORT, WRITE OR BROADCAST
STORIES THAT DEAL WITH MATTERS
OF LEGITIMATE PUBLIC IMPORTANCE.
THEY HELP US BUILD THE PUBLIC
TRUST. ALL OF US NEED THE FACTS,
THE CONTEXT AND THE FRAMING THAT
JOURNALISTS PROVIDE FOR US TO BE
INVOLVED IN EVERY PART OF
CITIZENSHIP, TO THINK, TO VOTE,
TO PARENT, TO INVEST, TO WORK
WITHOUT THE NEWS INDUSTRY AND
DEDICATED JOURNALISTS, WE
COULDN'T HOLD PEOPLE IN POWER
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T
KNOW WHAT THEY WERE DOING IN A
WORLD WITHOUT A FREE PRESS,
DISINFORMATION, RUMORS,
FALSEHOODS, AND FEAR MONGERING
CAN SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE. WE
CANNOT HAVE A TRULY FUNCTIONAL
DEMOCRACY WITHOUT A HEALTHY
FOURTH ESTATE TO REPORT ON THOSE
IN POWER. BUT IT'S NO EASY TASK
TO BE A JOURNALIST TODAY. JOB
INSTABILITY, LOW PAY, HIGH
TURNOVER ARE ALL A NORMAL PART
OF THE JOB IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES. IN PLACES,
JOURNALISTS ARE HARASSED,
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED OR EVEN
KILLED FOR JUST TRYING TO DO
THEIR JOBS, ACCORDING TO THE
INTERNATIONAL FEDERATION OF
JOURNALISTS, 120 JOURNALISTS AND
MEDIA WORKERS WERE KILLED IN
2023 FOR REASONS ASSOCIATED WITH
DOING THEIR JOB. I AM A FORMER
JOURNALIST, HAVING STARTED MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER AT THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES AND THEN WORKING
FOR THE ASSOCIATED PRESS BEFORE
GOING TO LAW SCHOOL. I ALSO HAVE
A BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S DEGREE
IN JOURNALISM FOR THE TEN YEARS
I'VE BEEN AN ELECTED, ELECTED
OFFICE, I'VE SENT WEEKLY OR BI
WEEKLY NEWSLETTERS THAT DRAW ON
MY JOURNALISM BACKGROUND IN THE
FORMAT AND TONE. I KNOW THAT
MOST OF US HERE ON THIS FLOOR
WAKE UP EACH MORNING AND READ
THE NEWS ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT HERE IN THE BUILDING, WITH
ALL THE REST OF US AND THE
LATEST HAPPENINGS THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION AND WORLD. WE ALL SEE THE
MEDIA AS A CRITICAL PART OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO. WE REFER TO
JOURNALISTS, WORK IN THE BILLS
WE WRITE, AND WE DEPEND ON THEM
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
LARGEST PROBLEMS WE FACE WITH
ALL THE LAWS WE DEVELOP AND PASS
IN THIS BUILDING. WE NEED THE
MEDIA COVERAGE SO THE PUBLIC
KNOWS WHAT IS HAPPENING, BUT
ALSO SO WE KNOW HOW PEOPLE ARE
RESPONDING. SO SIMPLY PUT, A
FREE, VIBRANT, DIVERSE,
ENERGETIC AND UNBIASED PRESS IS
CRITICAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY. SO
WITH THAT, I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND THE BRAVERY OF
JOURNALISTS EVERYWHERE AND THEIR
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT TO
REPORTING THE TRUTH. WE HONOR
THEM WITH THIS RESOLUTION, WHICH
RECOGNIZES THEIR HARD WORK AND
THE INDISPENSABLE SERVICE THEY
PROVIDE TO OUR DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR, SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND I
JUST WANTED TO STAND IN SUPPORT
OF MY GOOD COLLEAGUE WHO BROUGHT
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD. I, TOO,
AM A FORMER REFORM JOURNALIST,
STARTING MY CAREER AT THE
OAKLAND TRIBUNE, LATER AT THE
LONG BEACH, PRESS-TELEGRAM, AND
THEN CHICAGO TRIBUNE BEFORE
JOINING THE LABOR MOVEMENT AS A
RESEARCHER. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY HOW IN JEOPARDY THE FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND FREE PRESS IS IN
THIS COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA, AS
WE SEE CORPORATE CONSOLIDATION
OF OUR NEWS, IT IS NOT ONLY
THREATENING THE LIVES OF THESE
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS WHO PROVIDE
A CONSTITUTIONAL SERVICE TO US,
BUT IT ALSO LIMITS THE WAYS IN
WHICH OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY GOVERN THEMSELVES.
AND WE'RE HERE IN THIS CHAMBER,
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
CO-GOVERNING WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE WAY THAT
THEY CAN PARTICIPATE FULLY IN
THAT PROCESS IS THROUGH
INFORMATION AND THAT'S WHAT
JOURNALISTS BRING. THAT'S WHAT A
FREE PRESS BRINGS. AND I AM VERY
HONORED TO SUPPORT MY GOOD
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD. AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE, VOTE, SENATOR
DURAZO. THANK YOU. I ALSO DIDN'T
INTEND TO SPEAK, BUT BECAUSE OF
YOUR GREAT WORDS, I JUST WANTED
TO ALSO RAISE THE ISSUE OF
JOURNALISTS WHO, PRODUCE THE
NEWS IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. AND
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL IN A
STATE, IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA, VÀ, AND IN A NATION
LIKE THE US, WHERE WE'VE HAD
GENERATIONS AND GENERATIONS OF
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE NEWS,
TO THE TRUTH, TO WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGE, THEY TOO
COULD NOT PARTICIPATE FULLY IN
IN THIS DEMOCRACY. I REMEMBER
WHEN IT WAS THE YEAR OF THE
CENSUS, MY FIRST YEAR HERE IN
THE SENATE, AND WE HAD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE GOING TO,
PROVIDE THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE
TO REACH THOSE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA OR OTHER COMMUNITIES
OF DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. SO WHEN
IT CAME TO THE CENSUS, WHEN AND
THEY REALLY ASKED FOR HELP AND
THESE ARE ALSO TRUSTED TOOLS,
THEY'RE TRUSTED PEOPLE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. WHEN IT CAME TO THE
PANDEMIC, THEY ALSO RELIED ON
THEIR LOCAL NEWS AND NEWSPAPERS
AND MEDIA OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND IN THEIR LANGUAGE. SO I RISE
TO ADD THAT TO YOUR REMARKS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DURAZO. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION,
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR BLACKSHEAR,
YOU MAY CLOSE THE DEBATE. THANK
YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. I'LL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. DALLI.
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE OR
DODD. Ó JONES. AYE. LAIRD LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR AYE. MINH
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO AYE. OKOBO AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ HURTADO.
LAIRD. MCGUIRE. AYE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE LAST
TIME, PLEASE. CORTEZ AYE.
HURTADO. LAIRD ON A VOTE OF 38
TO 0, THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
RECOGNIZE SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR
FOR INTRODUCTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND ALSO TO MY
TWO COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE IN
SUPPORT. I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THE JOURNALISTS WHO ARE HERE
TODAY. WE HAVE SOME UP IN THE
GALLERY AND AT THE BACK HERE
STANDING. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON WITH OUR AGENDA OF THE DAY.
MEMBERS. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED RED.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVING
TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WE DON'T HAVE ANY HERE
AT THE DESK, SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE'LL BEGIN
FIRST WITH THE SECOND READING.
IF THE CLERK WOULD PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 918 WITH AMENDMENTS
940, WITH AMENDMENTS 1106, WITH
AMENDMENTS 1184, WITH AMENDMENTS
1146. WITH AMENDMENTS 1293. WITH
AMENDMENTS 913 99. SECOND
READING FOUR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA. FIRST ONE
UP IS FILE ITEM 18. YES, I KNOW
SENATOR GROVE IS GOING TO
PRESENT. SHE SEEMS READY. SO
WE'LL TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, MAJOR
GENERAL MATTHEW BEAVERS IS BEING
APPOINTED HOPEFULLY TODAY BY AS
THE ADJUTANT GENERAL OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT. PRIOR TO HIS
APPOINTMENT, HE HAD BEEN SERVING
AS AN ACTING ADJUTANT GENERAL
SINCE SEPTEMBER 2022. AND BEFORE
THAT, HE WAS A DEPUTY ADJUTANT
GENERAL. SINCE HIS GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT TO THAT POSITION IN
2011. HE'S AN INCREDIBLE LEADER
FOR OUR OUR MILITARY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR NEWMAN,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS NOMINATION.
I'VE KNOWN GENERAL BEAVERS SINCE
MY SERVICE AS THE AS THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE VETERANS
COMMITTEE. HE IS A FINE OFFICER,
A GOOD SOLDIER, AND A VERY GOOD
LEADER. AND WE'RE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE MY URGE, YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND I RISE AS THE
CHAIR OF THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS COMMITTEE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
APPOINTMENT OF MAJOR GENERAL
BEAVERS TO THE ROLE OF ADJUTANT
GENERAL. WHEN I FIRST WAS
ELECTED HERE IN THE SENATE,
MAJOR GENERAL BEAVERS SERVED AS
THE DEPUTY ADJUTANT GENERAL OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD.
IN THAT ROLE, HE HELPED LEAD
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD'S
RESPONSE TO A HISTORIC NUMBER OF
DISASTERS, INCLUDING WILDFIRES,
FLOODS AND AGAIN, COVID 19
PANDEMIC. THE STATE MISSION OF
THE NATIONAL GUARD IS TO PROVIDE
TRAINED AND DISCIPLINED FORCES
FOR DOMESTIC EMERGENCIES OR AS
OTHERWISE PROVIDED BY STATE LAW.
DURING HIS TIME AS ACTING
ADJUTANT GENERAL, MAJOR BEAVERS
DEMONSTRATED HIS UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO LEAD THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD WITH
INTEGRITY AND CLARITY. HIS
MILITARY BACKGROUND, AN ARRAY OF
EXPERIENCES MAKE HIM AN
EXCELLENT CANDIDATE FOR ADJUTANT
GENERAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AGAIN I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND MAJOR GENERAL BEAVERS.
HE HAS ALREADY AN INCREDIBLE
ASSET TO OUR STATE, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HIS CONTINUED PUBLIC
SERVICE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION, MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
GROVE, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
WHO SPOKE ON THIS CONFIRMATION.
HE WAS APPROVED AS A50 VOTE IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE,
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. AYE. OKOBOJI. AYE. PODIUM
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HURTADO LAIRD. NGUYEN
PORTANTINO. AYE. WILK ON A VOTE
OF 36 TO 0, THE NOMINEE IS
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 22.
THIS IS ANOTHER APPOINTMENT.
TURN NOW TO SENATOR GROVE FOR
PRESENTATION. SENATOR GROVE,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES JOSEPH MCCULLOUGH IS
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL.
PRIOR TO HIS ROLE, HE'D BEEN
SERVING AT ABC VÆ AS A CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR SINCE 2020. HE
STARTED HIS CAREER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN 2001 AS AN AGENT
ASSIGNED TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT OFFICE. HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON A50
VOTE ON THE 24TH OF APRIL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
NOMINEE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPERM AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. ADATO JONES. AYE.
LAIRD LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MEN I. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. AYE.
PODIUM AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. ISOTHERM AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CORTEZ AYE. HURTADO. LAIRD ON A
VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE NOMINEE IS
CONFIRMED. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 23. THE APPOINTMENT.
SENATOR GROVE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM NUMBER 23
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF NORMA
CAMPION. SHE'S A MEMBER OF THE
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD OF
STATE. EXCUSE ME. REAPPOINTMENT
TO THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. MISS
CAMPION IS CURRENTLY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE WOMEN'S
DEPARTMENT OF ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION, WHERE SHE STARTED AS
A LIFE COACH IN 2016, AND SHE
FIRST JOINED THE BOARD IN 2020
AND SERVES AS A PUBLIC MEMBER,
MISS CAMPION IS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS, I DON'T WANT TO SAY, AN
UNUSUAL APPOINTMENT TO THE
BOARD, BUT SHE'S GOING TO BE AN
ASSET TO THE BOARD WITH HER
LIVED LIFE EXPERIENCES, SHE WILL
BRING A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE TO
THIS BOARD, AND I THINK THAT IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED, SHE'S
INTELLIGENT, SHE'S SUPER SMART
ON THE ISSUES, AND SHE
UNDERSTANDS THE SYSTEM. AND SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SHE WAS APPOINTED OR
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL 24TH AT A50 VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR GROVE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS NOMINEE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN AYE. I'LL
RODIGO AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEAR BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE. HURTADO
JONES. LAIRD. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ AYE. HURTADO.
JONES AYE. LAIRD NGUYEN. SATO.
WILK ON A VOTE OF 35 TO 0, THE
NOMINEE IS CONFIRMED. MEMBERS.
HERE'S THE RUN OF THE SHOW FOR
THE REST OF THE MORNING. WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS ON SENATE THIRD
READING, AND THEN WE HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE YOU. SO
WE'LL BEGIN FIRST BY MOVING TO
SENATE. THIRD READING THIS IS
FILE ITEM 32, SR 79 BY SENATOR
MINH, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 79 BY SENATOR
MINH RELATIVE TO AAPI DAY
AGAINST BULLYING AND HATE.
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO SENATOR MINH.
SENATOR MINH, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I
FIRST WANT TO WISH YOU A HAPPY
AAPI HERITAGE MONTH. I'M
PRESENTING TWO RESOLUTIONS, THE
FIRST OF WHICH IS SR 79, WHICH
WOULD PROCLAIM MAY 18TH, 2024 AS
AAPI DAY AGAINST BULLYING AND
HATE IN HONOR OF ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH, AS WELL
AS THE ACT OF THE MURDER OF
VINCENT CHIN, MAY 18TH WAS THE
BIRTH DATE OF VINCENT CHIN, A
CHINESE AMERICAN WHO WAS
MURDERED IN 1982 AS A HATE
CRIME. THIS SENSELESS KILLING IN
DETROIT, SPARKED BY ANTI-ASIAN
ANTI JAPANESE ANIMOSITY, SPARKED
RECOGNITION WITHIN THE ÁP
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THE BULLYING AND
HATE OCCURRING. IN ACKNOWLEDGING
THIS DAY, WE'RE SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST MICROAGGRESSIONS AND
HARASSMENT AND HIGHLIGHTING THE
ALARMING INCREASE IN HATE THAT
WE'VE SEEN ACROSS THE BOARD,
INCLUDING AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
IN 2022, 81% OF ASIAN AMERICAN
YOUTH REPORTED BEING BULLIED OR
VERBALLY HARASSED BETWEEN MARCH
2020 AND MARCH 20TH, 23. STOP
AAPI HATE REPORT RECEIVED MORE
THAN 11,000 SELF-REPORTED
INCIDENTS OF ANTI-ASIAN HATE.
CALIFORNIA IS UNFORTUNATE AND
EMBARRASSINGLY ONE OF THE TOP
THREE STATES IN THIS REGARD.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE. SR 79
EXPRESSES OUR CONDEMNATION OF
HATE AND BULLYING, INCLUDING
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS. STATES THAT
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE AND THAT
WE NEED TO COMBAT ALL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR MINH. SENATOR WAHAB
, THANK YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE HERE. I DO REPRESENT A
ROUGHLY 55% ASIAN DISTRICT AND I
HEAR CONSISTENTLY FROM COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IN MY DISTRICT THAT THEY
ARE GENUINELY EVEN AFRAID TO
RIDE ON TRANSIT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN FACED WITH A
SIGNIFICANT UPTICK IN AAPI HATE.
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT JUST WITHIN, ONE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITY OF THE ASIAN,
CONTINENT. WE ALSO SEE
SIGNIFICANT HATE NOT ONLY WITH
OUR EAST ASIAN FRIENDS. WE SEE A
RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
HINDUPHOBIA AND SIKH PHOBIA AND
MUCH MORE, WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY
BEEN SEEING MORE AND MORE
AGGRESSIVE ATTACKS TO THOSE THAT
ARE VISIBLY DIFFERENT. AND THAT
IS A CONCERN, ESPECIALLY IN THIS
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WHEN
PEOPLE ARE WEARING EITHER A
HEADDRESS OR THEY LOOK DIFFERENT
OR THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT SKIN
COLOR AND MUCH MORE. THE FACT
THAT WE ARE IN 2024 AND STILL
TALKING ABOUT HATE TO ANY
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA IS
DISGUSTING. IT NEEDS TO STOP THE
STEREOTYPES, THE WHISPERS, THE
SUBLIMINAL CAMPAIGNS, AND SO, SO
MUCH MORE THAT WE SEE ACROSS
THIS STATE, BOTH POLITICALLY AS
WELL AS IN OUR NORMAL EVERYDAY
CONVERSATIONS NEEDS TO STOP. SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WAHAB. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR MINH, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD FOR THOSE COMMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE, I'LL RODA-GIL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DORADO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE OR DATO
JONES AYE. LAIRD. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OKOBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SATO AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. WHAT SHALL I CALL THE
CALL? THE ABSENT MEMBERS,
PLEASE. HURTADO LAIRD. MCGUIRE.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE. ON A VOTE
OF 38 TO 0, THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WILL MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 33. THIS IS SR 80
BY SENATOR MINH. SENATOR MINH,
LET'S READ THE RESOLUTION THÀNH
AND IT WILL WILL GO TO YOU NEXT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 80 BY SENATOR MINH,
RELATIVE TO AAPI WOMEN'S EQUAL
PAY DAY. SENATOR MINH. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SR 80,
WHICH RECOGNIZES MAY 3RD, 2024
AS AAPI WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY DAY.
THIS DAY IS MEANT TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THE PAY INEQUITIES
FACED BY AAPI WOMEN COMPARED TO
THEIR MALE AND WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. THE COMBINED
AVERAGE INCOME OF AAPI WOMEN IS
$0.80 FOR EVERY DOLLAR MADE BY
WHITE MEN IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THERE'S AN EVEN GREATER
DISPARITY IN CALIFORNIA, WHERE
AAPI WOMEN MAKE $0.72 FOR EVERY
DOLLAR MADE BY A WHITE MALE.
THESE DISPARITIES ARE ACTUALLY
MUCH WORSE THAN THEY SOUND,
BECAUSE ON AVERAGE, AAPI WOMEN
ARE 50% MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE, OVER 200%
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A ADVANCED
DEGREE, SUCH AS AN MBA OR LAW
DEGREE OR MD. AND SO THIS IS A
REAL, REAL HUGE GAP WE'RE
FACING. THIS WAGE GAP IS ALSO
MUCH MORE LARGE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT ETHNIC SUBGROUPS AND
DISAGGREGATION OF THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF APIS OUT THERE, SUCH AS
KOREAN AND MALAYSIAN WOMEN, WHO
EARN, ON AVERAGE, $0.77 ON THE
DOLLAR. INDONESIAN, CAMBODIAN
AND LAOTIAN WOMEN WHO EARN AN
AVERAGE $0.64. TONGAN AND
BHUTANESE WOMEN WHO EARN ON
AVERAGE $0.52, AND NEPALESE AND
BANGLADESHI WOMEN WHO EARN ON
AVERAGE $0.48 ON THE DOLLAR. IN
THE UNITED STATES, MANY OF THESE
WOMEN REPRESENT A SUBSTANTIAL
PROPORTION OF FRONTLINE
ESSENTIAL CARE WORKERS, WITH 27%
OF THEM BEING CLASSIFIED AS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE AAPI WOMEN WHO HELP
KEEP CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY MOVING
FORWARD, AND BY RECOGNIZING AAPI
WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY DAY, WE CAN
HOPEFULLY BEGIN TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS EQUALIZING THAT PAY GAP
AND ACKNOWLEDGING THE PROFOUND
ROLE THAT THESE WOMEN PLAY IN
THE WORKFORCE. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SR 80.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MINH. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AS
WELL AS THE AAPI CAUCUS, AND I
DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT EQUAL PAY
FOR EQUAL WORK. AND WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AAPI WOMEN AND
YES, THEY ARE PAID ACTUALLY
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER WOMAN
DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE WORKFORCE.
AND THAT'S STILL A PROBLEM. AND
WE'RE CONSISTENTLY FIGHTING
FORWARD. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WHEN PEOPLE COME TO
THIS COUNTRY, THEY DO COME HERE
FOR THE AMERICAN DREAM AND PART
OF THAT AMERICAN DREAM. AND I'VE
OFTEN SAID IT IS OBVIOUSLY HOME
OWNERSHIP, BUT IT'S ALSO
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. THE CONCERN THAT I SEE
HERE IS THE FACT THAT, AGAIN, WE
STILL CONTINUOUSLY TALK ABOUT
DISCRIMINATION. WE STILL SEE
OPEN SYSTEMIC DISCRIMINATION AND
THE FACT THAT WOMEN ARE PAID
LESS TO EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR A
MAN EARNS IS STILL VERY MUCH
PROBLEMATIC. AND IT'S EVEN
HARDER FOR CERTAIN SUBGROUPS. AS
MY COLLEAGUE STATED, MANY PEOPLE
, ESPECIALLY IMMIGRANT WOMEN WHO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY, DON'T ALL
COME ON A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
THERE ARE SOME WOMEN THAT COME
HERE WITH GREEN CARDS AND STATUS
AND THE SUPPORT OF THEIR
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS
BUSINESSES AND MUCH MORE. AND
THERE ARE SOME FOLKS THAT COME
HERE AS REFUGEES, ASYLUM SEEKERS
OR COMPLETELY UNDOCUMENTED IN
ANY WAY. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
STRUGGLE WITH LANGUAGE BARRIERS,
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR FAMILIES
ARE TAKEN CARE OF, MAKING SURE
THAT THEY HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD, AND MUCH MORE. AND YET
THEY STILL DO NOT GET PAID
EQUALLY. AND THIS IS MODERN DAY
SLAVERY. WE TALK ABOUT IT IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT WITH WAGE THEFT.
WE TALK ABOUT IT IN REGARDS TO A
NUMBER OF OTHER WAYS, AND YET WE
STILL CONTINUE TO SEE PEOPLE
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE MOST
MARGINALIZED AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, WHICH ARE WOMEN OF
COLOR. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND HOPE THAT NOBODY
ABSTAINS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WAHAB. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR. SENATOR MINU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD FOR HER SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ELLEN. AYE. I'LL
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO JONES.
AYE. LAIRD LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE OCHOA.
BOGUE PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK ON A
VOTE OF 30. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BARRASSO AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
HURTADO. LAIRD MENGIBAR. AYE
MIN. AYE. OCHOA AYE. SATO AYE.
WILK AYE. ALL RIGHT. ON A VOTE
OF 38 TO 0, THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS, WE HAVE ONE
LAST ITEM ON OUR THIRD READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 35 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR. NOW, WE ALREADY WE
ALREADY DID THAT ONE. THAT'S
RIGHT. DON'T PUT THAT IN MY
EVALUATION PLEASE. WE'RE GOING
TO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM 52. THIS IS SCR 134 BY
SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR GROVE,
WE'VE HEARD A LOT FROM YOU
TODAY, BUT WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO MORE COMMENTS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 134 BY
SENATOR GROVE RELATIVE TO CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH. SENATOR
GROVE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT SCR 134, WHICH
ACKNOWLEDGES APRIL 2024 AS CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH. IN 2022
COLLEAGUES, MORE THAN 50,000
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WERE
FOUND TO BE VICTIMS OF CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT, AND 164
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA DIED AS A
RESULT OF THAT ABUSE. THESE
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN ABUSED OR
NEGLECTED, HAVE A HIGHER RISK OF
DEVELOPING HEALTH PROBLEMS AS
ADULTS, INCLUDING ALCOHOLISM,
DEPRESSION, DRUG ABUSE, AND
TRAUMA. MALTREATED CHILDREN ARE
77% MORE LIKELY TO REQUIRE
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND 59% MORE
LIKELY TO BE ARRESTED AS
JUVENILES. IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, COLLEAGUES, THAT WE
CONTINUE THE FIGHT FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS OF CHILD
ABUSE IN ANY FORM. WE CANNOT
STAND SILENT AS MOST AT RISK.
THE MOST AT RISK AMONG US, AMONG
US ARE MALTREATED OR ABUSED,
OFTEN BY THOSE WHO THEY TRUST
MOST. AS MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE, WE'RE IN A UNIQUE
POSITION TO FIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN BY
SUPPORTING LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDES PROTECTION TO THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION. WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE SAD REALITY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS EXTREMELY HIGH
RATES OF CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING.
KIDS ALSO BEING LABOR TRAFFICKED
AND FORCED INTO A NEVER ENDING
CYCLE OF EXPLOITATION. THÀNH. WE
HAVE A HISTORY OF INSTITUTIONAL
ABUSE, ESPECIALLY AMONG OUR
YOUNG FOSTER YOUTH AND A NUMBER
OF HOMELESS YOUTH IN THE STATE,
AND IT'S COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE
THE ABUSES OF TRAUMAS AND
TRAUMAS OF THESE CHILDREN THAT
THEY FACE LEAD TO A LIFETIME OF
NEGATIVE EFFECTS. THE LONG TERM
HEALTH CARE COSTS FOR ADULT
SURVIVORS AND CHILDHOOD PHYSICAL
AND SEXUAL ABUSE ARE 21% HIGHER
THAN NON-VICTIMS. CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN DESERVE TO GROW UP IN A
SAFE AND NURTURING ENVIRONMENT,
FREE FROM FEAR, ABUSE AND
NEGLECT, AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE STOOD SIDE
BY SIDE WITH ME TO FIGHT FOR THE
FUTURE OF FREE FROM ABUSES IN
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA AND
SEVERAL PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT WENT THROUGH THE BUILDING
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING SCR 134
AND ACKNOWLEDGING THE CONTINUED
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE AS
LEGISLATORS TO PROTECT CHILDREN.
OAN AND I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY,
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND AS
A PROUD COAUTHOR TO SCR 134,
ACKNOWLEDGING APRIL 2024 AS
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH AND
I WANT TO THANK THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR
INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION AND
FOR HER TIRELESS EFFORTS IN
TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN. AND I
REALLY WANT TO SAY I ADMIRE HER
COURAGE FOR PUSHING FORWARD WITH
THINGS THAT ARE DIFFICULT,
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
DIFFICULT, BUT WE HAVE MOVED THE
NEEDLE. WE JUST NEED TO GET
THERE A LITTLE FASTER AND
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN. AS A
VICTIMS ADVOCATE, I GET TO HEAR
HUNDREDS OF STORIES OF CHILDREN
AND NOW ADULTS WHO TELL ME THEIR
STORIES AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT MANY OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
BEING ABUSED BY THEIR OWN
FAMILIES. AND SOMETIMES WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE THAT. AND I OFTEN TAKE
THE TIME TO URGE EVERYONE TO PAY
ATTENTION. WE ALWAYS PAY
ATTENTION TO STRANGERS ABUSING
OUR CHILDREN, BUT YET WE DON'T
PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING INSIDE OUR HOME. AND I
HAVE HEARD STORIES, AS I
MENTIONED, ONE LITTLE GIRL WHO
IS FIVE AND IT WAS HER MOTHER
WHO STARTED ABUSING HER AND THEN
PASSING HER AROUND WITH ADULT
MEN. AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CONTINUES TO REALLY KEEP ME UP
AT NIGHT. LIKE I SAID,
COLLECTIVELY WE MOVED THE
NEEDLE, BUT IT CANNOT GET THERE
FAST ENOUGH. OUR CHILDREN
DESERVE BETTER. OFTEN AS THEY
GROW UP AS ADULTS, THEY CONTINUE
TO GO THROUGH THIS DARK TUNNEL
OF, ALCOHOL ABUSE, SEXUAL ABUSE.
THEY DON'T FEEL WORTHY. AND THE
CYCLE OF ABUSE CONTINUES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T FEEL WORTHY. AND SO
WE NEED TO DO BETTER. AND TODAY
I'M REALLY HONORED TO STAND HERE
TO SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION, TO
SPREAD AWARENESS AND BE ABLE TO
ENCOURAGE PROACTIVENESS IN
SUPPORTING CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
CRITICAL RESOURCES THAT THESE
CHILDREN NEED. SO I URGE AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU. I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS. I ALSO URGE AN
AYE VOTE. I THINK THAT CHILDREN
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. IN PARTICULAR, THEY
DO NOT HAVE AN ADVOCATE.
OFTENTIMES, IF THEY'RE NOT IN
THE SYSTEM, THEY DO NOT HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY CAN SPEAK
TO, ESPECIALLY CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THAT STILL FIND IT A
PROBLEM TO RAISE THEIR CONCERNS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND ALLOW FOR
CHILDREN TO HAVE CERTAIN RIGHTS
TO TALK TO A COUNSELOR, TO TALK
TO A THERAPIST, TO TALK TO A
TEACHER. THIS IS WHY WE HAVE SO
MANY, GOOD STEWARDS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT ARE MANDATED
REPORTERS AND MUCH MORE. WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE.
I WILL SAY IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE ABUSE THAT HAPPENS RIGHT
THEN AND THERE. YOU KNOW, I
THINK ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID
THIS IN A PREVIOUS CONVERSATION,
OAN THAT BRUISES HEAL BROKEN
BONES HEAL. HOWEVER, THE TRAUMA
MENTALLY AND EMOTIONALLY LASTS A
LIFETIME. AND WE DO HAVE TO
INVEST AS A STATE INTO HOUSING
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS, INTO
HEALTH CARE AND TREATMENT FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS, INTO ACTUAL
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT
ACTUALLY CARRY THEM FOR A
LIFETIME. THIS IS INCLUDING
EDUCATION AND MUCH MORE. THIS IS
LITERALLY WHAT WE CAN DO AS
LEGISLATORS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
CONDEMNING THE ABUSER, BUT IT'S
ALSO ABOUT UPLIFTING THE CHILD
AS A WHOLE AND THAT ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. SO THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING
NONE, SENATOR GROVE, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN PARK AND HAYWARD FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTIONS. AYES 38. NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO TURN
NEXT TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR AND
OUR SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO REMOVE
ANYTHING FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDARS? ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
REQUEST TO REMOVE ANYTHING, THE
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 925 1371 1523. SENATE
RESOLUTION 88. SENATE BILL 1525
1117 1198 1226 1473 1493. SENATE
RESOLUTION 90. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 157 164
165. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. BARRASSO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I
MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO AYE. OKOBOJI PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO. LAIRD OTOBOKE. AYE.
THAT'S 38 ZERO ON FILE ITEM 102
38 ZERO ON THE BALANCE OF THE
CONSENT AND THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE WE HAVE A
FEW TO DO. BEGIN WITH SENATOR
MENGIBAR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. MEMBERS. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, NUMBER THREE. SO I WAS
WAITING FOR NUMBER THREE TO COME
UP. MR. PRESIDENT, BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET IN 1215 MINUTES AFTER
SESSION. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PETILLA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT, BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION WILL
CONVENE HERE IN THE CAPITOL ROOM
113, 15 MINUTES FOLLOWING
ADJOURN. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PADILLA. SENATOR WAHAB, THANK
YOU. BUDGET SUB FIVE IN ROOM
ONE, 12, 15 MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, THAT COMPLETES OUR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
WHERE WE HAVE SOME FOLKS WHO
WANT TO SHARE SOME ADJOURN IN
MEMORY REQUESTS. ASK ALL THE
MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THEIR
CHAIRS. PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN FIRST WITH SENATOR ASHBY.
SENATOR ASHBY, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF THOMAS SAMUEL
AUGUSTA, WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY 6TH, 2024. THOMAS
AUGUSTA IS THE FATHER OF OUR
SENATE STAFFER, FRANKIE AUGUSTA,
WHO SERVES US HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS AS PART OF OUR TECH
SUPPORT TEAM. TOMMY WAS A
BELOVED AND LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO AND WAS BORN IN
SACRAMENTO ON AUGUST 10TH, 1933.
THOMAS ATTENDED SACRAMENTO HIGH
SCHOOL AND WAS A FOOTBALL STAR
AS WELL AS BASKETBALL AND
BASEBALL. HE ATTENDED JUNIOR
COLLEGE HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
ENJOYED SEVEN YEARS OF
PROFESSIONAL MINOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL CAREER. HE PLAYED
OUTFIELD FOR 83 GAMES FOR THE
1954 BROOK ARMY MEDICAL CENTER
COMETS AT FORT SAM HOUSTON IN
TEXAS. HE WAS SIGNED BY THE
SACRAMENTO SOLONS, A
PROFESSIONAL TEAM THAT WAS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO FOR A WHILE IN
1953, AND WAS LATER DRAFTED INTO
THE UNITED STATES ARMY, WHERE HE
SERVED HONORABLY. AFTER HIS TIME
IN THE SERVICE, HE RETURNED HOME
TO SACRAMENTO AND PLAYED SIX
MORE YEARS OF PROFESSIONAL
BASEBALL. HE IS MEMORIALIZED AT
THE RIVER CAT STADIUM IN WEST
SACRAMENTO ON A PLAQUE AND IN A
MURAL WITH MANY OF THE PREVIOUS
PLAYERS. IN 1964, HE JOINED THE
SACRAMENTO CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT,
WHERE HE ENJOYED A 28 YEAR
CAREER AS AN ENGINEER, HE ALWAYS
RESPECTED THE JOB AND HIS FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS. WHEN COLLEAGUES
WERE SERIOUSLY HURT OR DISABLED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY, HE MADE IT
A PRIORITY TO GO SPEND TIME WITH
THEM AND REMIND THEM THAT THEY
WERE PART OF THE FAMILY. THOMAS
MET HIS WIFE WHEN HE WAS JUST 12
YEARS OLD, WALKING TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD MARKET. THEY BECAME
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEARTS AND WERE
MARRIED IN 1956. WENT ON TO
RAISE THEIR FAMILY, INCLUDING
OUR FRIEND HERE IN SACRAMENTO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, I OFFER MY CONDOLENCES
TO THOMAS'S ENTIRE FAMILY. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF 67
YEARS, JOYCE AUGUSTA. HIS SON
FRANKIE, DAUGHTER ELIZABETH,
DAUGHTER IN LAW, SALLY, AND
GRANDCHILDREN CAITLIN, NICK AND
JAKE. FRANKIE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE WILL
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE NAME OF
YOUR FATHER. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ASHBY. THE SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO YOUR FAMILY. ALL
THE FRIENDS OF MR. AUGUSTA,
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD,
SENATOR ASHBY, SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL. AND WE MAY
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. NEXT UP,
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO REQUEST
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
DAVID SERRANO, WHO PASSED AWAY
ON THE EVENING OF FEBRUARY 25TH,
2020. FOR THE COMMUNITY OF LA
GRANDE IN MERCED COUNTY AND
OTHERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY, WE
MOURN THE LOSS OF A COMMUNITY
LEADER AND DEVOTED FATHER. DAVID
SERRANO WAS BORN ON AUGUST 13TH,
1941, TO FLORENCIO AND ANITA
SERRANO IN COALINGA, CALIFORNIA,
ALONGSIDE HIS TWIN BROTHER
DANIEL, WHO WHO LIVED ONLY A
SHORT TIME. DAVE, AS HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS CALLED HIM, RECEIVED
HIS EARLY EDUCATION FROM
PLAINSBURG ELEMENTARY AND OTHER
CHOWCHILLA GRAMMAR SCHOOLS.
GROWING UP, HE WAS CONSTANTLY
BUSY IN MOTION, VERY CREATIVE,
AND FOREVER INTERESTED IN
BUILDING THINGS WITH METAL AND
WOOD. FOLLOWING HIS GRADUATION
FROM CHOWCHILLA HIGH SCHOOL IN
1959, DAVE SERRANO ATTENDED
FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY, WHERE
HE GRADUATED WITH A BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE IN AGRONOMY. IN HIS
YEARS AT FRESNO STATE, DAVID
SERRANO, WITH THE HELP OF HIS
FRIENDS, CREATED THEIR OWN
CAMERA CLUB AND HE TOOK
PHOTOGRAPHS FOR THE SCHOOL
YEARBOOK. HE ALSO FOUND TIME TO
BUILD ANIMAL PENS AT THE FRESNO
STATE DAIRY UNTIL MOST NOTABLY
DURING THIS TIME HE WAS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED WITH THE NEWMAN CENTER
AT FRESNO STATE, WHERE HE MET
ROSEANNE BURKHART, THE LOVE OF
HIS LIFE, WHO HE MARRIED ON MAY
13TH, 1967, AT THE NEWMAN CENTER
. DAVID SERRANO AND ROSEANNE
BURKHART WERE MARRIED FOR 50
YEARS AND BROUGHT FOUR CHILDREN
INTO THE WORLD. ROSEANNE AND
DAVID SERRANO WORKED ALONGSIDE
THE SERRANO IN-LAWS, AND WHEN
THE FARM WAS PASSED DOWN, THEY
TOOK MUCH PRIDE IN GROWING
ALMONDS, CORN, WHEAT, SORGHUM,
APRICOTS, AND COTTON. THEY ALSO
RAISED A SMALL HERD OF SHEEP TO
KEEP DAVID DAVE SERRANO'S
GRANDFATHER'S LEGACY ALIVE. HE
LOVED FARMING AND WATCHING
PLANTS GROW. IT BROUGHT HIM JOY
TO SEE THE CIRCLE OF LIFE, EVEN
WHEN FARMING WAS HARD WORK.
DAVID SERRANO WAS DEDICATED TO
FAITH, FAMILY AND COMMUNITY, AND
SERVED AS A LECTOR, EUCHARISTIC
EUCHARISTIC MINISTER, AND TOOK
UP COLLECTION ON SATURDAY NIGHT
MASS AT OUR LADY OF LOURDES
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN LA GRANDE. HE
SERVED ON THE PLAINSBURG
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BOARD AND THE
LA GRANDE UNION HIGH SCHOOL
BOARD, AND SERVED AS PRESIDENT
OF THE MERCED COUNTY FARM
BUREAU, AND WAS A LONG STANDING
MEMBER OF THE LA GRANDE ANTHONY
WATER DISTRICT AND NUMEROUS
OTHER AGRICULTURAL AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS IS THE
LIFEBLOOD OF RURAL CALIFORNIA.
DAVE SERRANO WAS PROUD OF HIS
BASQUE HERITAGE AND EMBODIED THE
BASQUE PROVERB SUCCESS IS THE
RESULT OF A LOT OF HARD WORK. BY
EARNING ACCOLADES SUCH AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S
SMALL BUSINESS PERSON OF THE
YEAR, MERCED COUNTY OUTSTANDING
TREE AND VINES AWARD IN THE LA
GRANDE COMMUNITY DAY CITIZEN OF
THE YEAR. DAVID SERRANO WAS WELL
LOVED AND RESPECTED IN HIS
COMMUNITY. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
FOUR CHILDREN CHRISTINE SERRANO,
DANIELLE SERRANO, MATTHEW
SERRANO AND MICHAEL SERRANO, AND
HIS FIVE GRANDCHILDREN,
ISABELLA, WILLIAM, CATALINA,
MADISON AND A BABY GIRL.
ARRIVING IN MAY, DAVID SERRANO
WAS DEEPLY LOVED AND WILL BE
MISSED. HE WILL BE REMEMBERED AS
A GENTLEMAN IN HIS COMMUNITY AND
HIS FAMILY, SAYS HE WAS A
GOOFBALL AT HOME. I OFFER MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO DAVID
SERRANO'S FAMILY, FRIENDS,
COLLEAGUES AND COMMUNITY. MAY HE
HAVE THE SPECIAL PLACE IN HEAVEN
RESERVED FOR THOSE WHO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COMMUNITY, AND
MAY HE REST IN ETERNAL PEACE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS, AND I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN THE SENATE TODAY
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CABALLERO. THE SENATE
EXTENDS ITS CONDOLENCES TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF MR.
SERRANO. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY,
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL, AS WE HAD
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. NEXT
UP, WE WANT TO ASK SENATOR
UMBERG TO HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO HONOR THE
LIFE AND THE MEMORY OF VICKIE.
SAMMY VENTO. VICKIE WAS A
COMPASSIONATE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
PERSONAL INJURY LAWYER FOR 36
YEARS. SHE PASSED AWAY MUCH,
MUCH TOO EARLY IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR. SHE WAS BORN ON
OCTOBER 27TH, 1958, TO HER
PARENTS, VICENTE AND IRMA, IN
BOLIVIA. VICKIE ARRIVED IN THE
UNITED STATES WHEN SHE WAS SIX.
GROWING UP ON EASTWOOD AVENUE IN
SANTA ANA, CALIFORNIA, WITH HER
BROTHER AND SISTER VINCE AND
DAISY, VICKIE WENT TO SCHOOL IN
SANTA ANA, ATTENDING JOHN MUIR
ELEMENTARY. LATHROP
INTERMEDIATE, AND SANTA ANA HIGH
SCHOOL. SHE WAS TRULY A DAUGHTER
OF SANTA ANA. WHEN VICKIE TURNED
15, SHE STARTED WORKING AT THE
LAW OFFICES OF MILTON C GRIMES,
WHERE SHE FOUND A LOVE OF THE
LAW AND MENTORS MILTON AND
ELOISE GRIMES. AFTER VICKIE
GRADUATED FROM SANTA ANA HIGH,
SHE ATTENDED UC IRVINE, WHERE
SHE RECEIVED A BACHELOR IN
SCIENCE IN SOCIAL SCIENCE AND
BACHELOR OF ARTS IN SPANISH
LITERATURE. FOLLOWING HER
GRADUATION FROM UCI, SHE
ATTENDED UC COLLEGE OF LAW IN
SAN FRANCISCO, WHERE SHE EARNED
HER JURIS DOCTOR. IN. HER WORK
IN CIVIL RIGHTS, STARTED EARLY
WHILE ATTENDING UCI, SHE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF MUJERES
LATINAS, WHERE SHE ORGANIZED FOR
THE RIGHTS OF MINORITIES AND
WOMEN. SIMILARLY, AT UC LAW, SAN
FRANCISCO, SHE WAS PRESIDENT OF
THE LA RAZA LAW STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION, AN ORGANIZATION
THAT AIMED TO RECRUIT LATINO LAW
STUDENTS TO PROVIDE COMMUNITY
SERVICE FOR IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES IN SAN FRANCISCO. IN
1988, SHE WAS ADMITTED TO THE
STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA, AND SHE
BEGAN WORK AT THE LA CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, A FEW YEARS
LATER, VICKIE BEGAN HER OWN LAW
PRACTICE IN PERSONAL INJURY AND
CIVIL RIGHTS LAW. SHE
SPECIALIZED IN CASES INVOLVING
INJURY OR WRONGFUL DEATH,
PARTICULARLY STEMMING FROM
POLICE BRUTALITY, EXCESSIVE
FORCE IN CUSTODY, DEATHS, DENIAL
OF MEDICAL CARE TO INMATES,
ASSAULTS AND SEXUAL ABUSE OF
MINORS AND JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES, WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS
AND RACIAL PROFILING. MANY OF
HER CASES WERE IMPACTFUL FAR
BEYOND THE INDIVIDUAL PARTIES
AND IGNITED SYSTEMIC CHANGE.
VICKIE WAS A COMPASSIONATE,
EMPATHETIC, DEDICATED WOMAN WHO
PUT THE LIVES OF OTHERS IN FRONT
OF HER OWN. COINED AS A QUOTE,
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWYER EXCUSE ME,
CIVIL RIGHTS WARRIOR. END QUOTE.
VICKIE WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED FOR CHANGING THE
LIVES OF HER CLIENTS, HER
FAMILY, AND SO MANY OTHERS.
VICKIE IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND, DALE GALIPO, WHO IS
ALSO A CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
HER SIBLINGS. ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERVISOR VINCE SARMIENTO,
DAISY SARMIENTO, AND MANY
FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES WHO MOURN
HER DEATH. COLLEAGUES I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF
VICKIE SARMIENTO. THANK YOU,
SENATOR AYZENBERG. THE SENATE
EXTENDS ITS CONDOLENCE TO THE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF MISS
SARMIENTO. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL, AND THAT WE MAY ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE. SENATOR MCGUIRE NØ.
THERE HE IS, SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THE DESK IS CLEAR. AS THEY MAKE
THE LONG TREK, THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY,
MAY 6TH AT 2 P.M. HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT 2 P.M.